hi this is kim from khan academy today
we're learning more about roe vs wade
the 1973 supreme court case that ruled
that the right of privacy extends to a
woman's decision to have an abortion to
learn more about roe vs wade i spoke to
two experts on the case clark forsyth is
senior counsel for americans united for
life and the author of abuse of
discretion the inside story of roe
versus wade melissa murray is the
alexander f and may t morrison professor
of law at berkeley law school where she
also serves as the faculty director for
the center on reproductive rights and
justice mr forsyth could you set this
stage for us a little bit what was going
on at this time period well there were
efforts in the
1960s to
repeal abortion laws in the states and
when that when act abortion activists
were dissatisfied with those efforts
they decided to go into the courts and
around 1969
they took some cases into the courts and
ultimately there were 20 or more cases
challenging state laws
in the courts between 1969
and 1973
and
roe versus wade was a case from texas
roe was litigated in the early 1970s it
was a period of enormous change in the
united states we were beginning to see
the beginnings of the women's rights
movements the beginnings of the gay
rights movement and of course the civil
rights movement of the 1960s was moving
in a lot of different directions at the
time
the question of abortion was very much
on the minds of lots of different state
legislatures because there had been
moves to liberalize much of the criminal
law that dealt with matters of sex and
sexuality including abortion
at the time four states new york alaska
hawaii
and i believe washington had actually
taken steps to repeal their laws
criminalizing abortion
and about 13 other states had taken
efforts to
liberalize their laws criminalizing
abortions but in a number of other
states around
at least 20 or more
there remained on the books laws that
absolutely criminalized abortion except
in situations where it would be
necessary to preserve the woman's health
or life or in cases of rape incest or
fetal anomaly abortion rights attorneys
sought plaintiffs
who could challenge the texas law and
the georgia law there were
two attorneys from texas
who found
norma mccorvey
who they named gave the pseudonym of
jane rowe for purposes of protecting her
privacy and she became the
nominal plaintiff and so norma mccorvey
brought this case um she was a 22 year
old woman living in dallas county texas
who found herself pregnant for the third
time she was unmarried
her first child had been born a daughter
and she had ultimately signed over
custody of her daughter to her mother to
raise because she was um
having a bit of an itinerant life was
unable to take care of her child
the second child that she bore she gave
up for adoption and so when she found
herself pregnant for a third time she
wasn't willing to do either of these
things again and wanted to safely and
legally terminate her pregnancy but this
was impossible under the texas law texas
had since the 19th century absolutely
criminalized abortion except in cases
where it was necessary for the health
and safety of the mother and so she then
was faced with the question of what she
what was she going to do and the only
thing she could think to do then was to
actually challenge the law
so she was put in contact with sarah
weddington and linda coffey two young
women who had recently graduated from
law school sarah weddington was only 26
years old at the time that she helped
norma mccorvey bring this case but they
decided to sue the state of texas to
challenge the constitutionality of
texas's criminal abortion ban but as the
as the history shows uh there was no
trial there was no evidence there were
no expert witnesses jane roe never
testified
as you know she never
got an abortion she
gave birth and placed her child for
adoption okay so roe was
norma mccorvey who was wade henry wade
was the district attorney for dallas
texas
where the case was filed
in
federal district court so
this case i assume kind of wins its way
through the courts
and how did the supreme court rule the
justices
declared the texas and georgia laws
unconstitutional
and then rewrote a
national law a national abortion law
in which they said that the states could
not regulate or limit abortion in the
first trimester
they could
regulate more in the second trimester
the second three months of pregnancy
to protect maternal health
and they could regulate in the last
three months of pregnancy the last
trimester
to protect maternal health or fetal life
the attorneys for the plaintiffs
claim that this that abortion fell
within the right to privacy
even though privacy is not in the text
of the constitution
they said it was derived or based in the
language of the 14th amendment to the
constitution even though the 14th
amendment doesn't say anything about
abortion or the unborn child it
just uses the term liberty and
ultimately the court said that the
right to abortion was part of the right
to privacy based on the 14th amendment
that's very interesting so i've learned
through many of these interviews that
this right to privacy is something that
is never actually explicitly stated
throughout the bill of rights but
there's a
penumbra of privacy that you see in a
few ways what was the court's reasoning
that it was abortion that could fall
under this zone of privacy if you read
the real opinion uh on page 152 of the
row opinion
justice blackman starts out by saying
that
he cites a string of cases since about
a string of supreme court cases and says
that these lead to the right of privacy
and we think abortion or that the right
of privacy is broad enough to encompass
abortion but then four pages later on
page 156 blackman turns around and says
but abortion because it involves the
taking of a life is inherently different
from all those other cases that make up
the right of privacy so the right of
privacy doesn't actually come from roe
versus wade it comes from a case decided
about nine or eight years earlier in
1965 called griswold versus connecticut
in griswold at issue was a connecticut
state statute that made it a crime to
use contraception or even to counsel
patients about contraception planned
parenthood
league of connecticut opened up a birth
control clinic in new haven connecticut
they were promptly arrested and the
clinic was closed and then they were
able to bring this case
and um they argued that the right to be
able to use contraception was the right
of the individual the right of the
doctor to advise patients about
contraception was also an individual
right
and the court in an opinion authored by
william o douglas agrees with them
and the court articulates for the first
time this right of privacy and this is a
right that the majority in griswold says
has actually been percolating in the
court's decisions for some time did any
of the justice's dissent in the road
decision and if so why well there were
two dissents
by justice
white and by justice
rehnquist
and justice white said that
the court was engaging in raw judicial
power
and that
the justices did not have
the right
or the authority to strike down
the abortion laws of the states and
uh could not rely upon a doctrine called
substantive due process justice
rehnquist said that there is
clear
historical evidence that many states
passed abortion limits and prohibitions
precisely at the time of the framing of
the 14th amendment in 18
the 1860s leading up to 1868 and that
the evidentiary history this history of
state limits and prohibitions on
abortion
contradicted any proposition that the
14th amendment was intended to include a
right to abortion and that was kind of
the heart of his
descent so roe was not the last word on
abortion in the united states there have
been several later cases that were
important to this as well like planned
parenthood versus casey or whole women's
health versus heller stat can you talk a
little bit about how those cases have
altered the scope of the right to
abortion as soon as roe is decided in
there is an effort to sort of roll it
back and and hem it in a little bit
frank church who's a senator from idaho
announces the church amendment um which
basically says that physicians don't
have to
perform abortions if doing so would
conflict with their conscience or
conscience beliefs so again that's one
opportunity to sort of limit the reach
of this right by limiting the number of
providers who are available to offer
abortions in fact the court
has
kind of cut back on roe versus wade in
four cases over the years um harris
versus mcrae involving abortion funding
planned parenthood versus casey
and in other cases they've given more
deference to the states allowed the
states to pass
more and more limits uh at least around
the margins even though they've
continued the
uh holding to the basic right that uh
that roe created that there is a right
to abortion for virtually any reason at
any time of pregnancy that's still the
scope of the right
but they've allowed marginal regulations
like limits on public funding parental
notice and consent informed consent laws
but then the court flip-flopped in
2016 in june of 2016 in whole women's
health versus hellerstadt the case makes
its way
to the supreme court and in an opinion
that's authored by justice stephen
breyer and it's only an eight-person
court because justice scalia passes away
in february of 2016 so just eight people
on the court
in this decision that's a five to three
decision justice stephen breyer notes
that the provisions that were challenged
do not offer the medical benefits that
they claim to offer sufficient to
justify the burdens on access that each
of those provisions imposes what do you
see as the future of roe versus wade
well the court has failed as the
national abortion control board it
cannot
monitor abortion it can't intervene it
can't regulate or legislate itself
it can't act as public health
administrators it can't investigate
and i
i believe it's
absolutely certain that the court sooner
or later will have to overturn the roe
versus wade decision because of this
failure and return the issue of the
states when we are talking about
repealing or reforming these laws in the
1960s and 70s it's also around a social
movement where one of the critical
questions is what will be the role of
women going forth in a modern society
when the questions of contraception come
before the court one of the questions is
whether women will be allowed to choose
when and how to have children whether
they can space the timing of births to
accommodate careers it's the same issue
that comes up in abortion like this is
allowing women
freedom to be able to go into the
workforce to determine when and how they
will become mothers and so it's not
surprising that the same questions that
arose in the 19th century about the
place of women about what happens in a
society that's undergoing change whether
it's immigration or changes in the
demography of the country are also
coming up in the 1960s and 1970s at a
time of incredible social change and i
think abortion
and these rights involving a woman's
role really do come to the fore and are
incredibly controversial so we've
learned that the decision to legalize
abortion in roe versus wade was based on
the right of privacy which the court has
inferred from the due process clause of
the 14th amendment since the row
decision a number of other cases have
set limits on abortion and abortion
clinics clark forsyth argues that the
supreme court has failed in regulating
abortion and that the issue should be
returned to the states melissa murray by
contrast suggests that the decision in
row is crucial to giving women the
freedom to join the workforce and make
decisions about when to have children to
learn more about this case visit the
national constitution center's
interactive constitution and khan
academy's resources on u.s government
and politics